hello and welcome to episode two and how
to start a fashion business series
episode one was featuring Calvin Klein
and it was on how to find your passion
if you missed it you could check it out
here today's lesson features Vera Wang
and it's work to learn if you don't have
a lot of experience in the fashion
industry yet
your best bet isn't to jump in and start
your own business it's the go work for
somebody who's currently doing what
you're trying to do that way you can
make your mistakes and get paid to do it
while learning about your industry when
Vera Wang was 21 years old she wanted to
get in the fashion business but she had
zero experience so she went to go work
for Vogue magazine working as an
assistant to paly mellon who was the
fashion director she worked hard learned
the ropes and within two years became
the magazine's fashion editor she was 23
years old
she was in a demanding position working
every weekend in every evening but she
knew that the experience would be worth
it now she stayed with Vogue magazine
for 15 years but then she started to get
restless I wanted to get into the design
of fashion but before starting her own
business she wanted to work for someone
who had a lot of experience in that
field and that was Ralph Lauren so she
left vogue to become the design director
for accessories for Ralph Lauren where
she stayed there for two years she
learned everything she needed to learn
about designing then was ready to launch
her own business creating wedding gowns
fast forward to today and she's a brand
name designer creating collections for
some of the richest and most famous
people in the world her advice for
people who are just starting up is go
work for somebody and get paid to learn
it's tempting to think you can go off
and do your own thing but there is so
much to learn in ways you'd never know
now you don't need to go and spend 17
years working for somebody else before
you can launch your business but it also
might be foolish to think you can just
jump in and have success right away find
a company that you look up to find a
company that you want to be like in a
couple years go work for them and get us
close to the entrepreneur founder as
possible taking on as many
responsibilities as you can because
you're they're not too
money but to learn about the business
you're getting paid to make mistakes
you're getting paid to make connections
you're getting paid to understand how
the industry works you might be there
for six months a year two years three
years but when you feel like you've
learned everything you need to learn and
you're ready to go start your business
you'll have a much higher degree of
becoming successful now you might be
frustrated you might be anxious you
might be ready to start your business
right now and say how do I want to start
it right now how do I start going right
now but for a lot of you if you don't
have the experience your best next step
is to go work for somebody else instead
of starting your company right now go
learn from them and dramatically
increase the chance of you becoming
successful in the fashion business
believe for those of you watching you
like the video let me know what you
think in the comments below and
subscribe to the channel if you want to
see more videos like this thank you so
much for watching and I'll see you soon
self-improvement books are like fitness
books they never work on their own what
you need is a trainer that's even gab
the newsletter
you